Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. report come x2 jews who escaped birkenau correctness whereof confirmed from the beginning june 1943 90 incoming jews gassed death stop three gas chambers four crematoriums birkenau auschwitz, stop. So that was a telegram from the British journalist Walter Garrett, sent in June 1944 to London. And that's the moment in many ways, isn't it, Tom, when the first revelations of the death camp at Auschwitz begin to percolate out. And it's thanks to this report that we talked about last time
感谢收听《历史的剩余》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听资格，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。报告称 x2 名逃离比克瑙的犹太人，其真实性自 1943 年 6 月初起得到证实，90 名新入营犹太人被毒气杀害，句号。三个毒气室，四个焚尸炉，比克瑙奥斯威辛，句号。所以那是英国记者沃尔特·加勒特于 1944 年 6 月发往伦敦的一份电报。在很多方面，这正是奥斯威辛死亡集中营的第一次内幕消息开始渗漏出来的时刻，对吧，汤姆？正是多亏了我们上次谈到的这份报告
by these two extraordinary men, Rudolf Verber and Fred Wetzler. And we're joined by Jonathan Friedland again, whose book The Escape Artist chronicles this incredibly haunting and riveting story. Jonathan, welcome back to The Rest is History. Thank you. Good to be with you. So we ended last time, didn't we, with Churchill. You had the report on Churchill's desk.
这两位非凡的人物：鲁道夫·韦尔巴和弗雷德·韦茨勒。我们再次邀请到了乔纳森·弗里德兰，他的书《逃生大师》记录了这个极其挥之不去且引人入胜的故事。乔纳森，欢迎再次来到《历史的剩余》。谢谢。很高兴能与你们在一起。所以我们上次结束时，提到了丘吉尔，对吧？丘吉尔的桌上摆着那份报告。
What can be said? What can be done? This is, you know, let's just go into this because it's such a big question. What can be done, would you say, in the summer of 1944? So the report, now known as the Werber-Wetzlar Report, that these two escapees have dictated, in effect, 32-page, single-space, full of the evidence of what's happened, of what is happening in Auschwitz-Birkenau, has made its way to these various, you know, chancellories of government. On its journey, it's changed because now attached to it, almost physically attached,
能说些什么？能做些什么？你知道的，让我们深入探讨一下这个问题，因为这是一个如此宏大的问题。你认为在 1944 年夏天，能做些什么呢？因此，这份现在被称为《韦尔巴-韦茨勒报告》的文件——这两位逃亡者实际上口述了一份 32 页、单倍行距、充满了奥斯威辛-比克瑙发生过的事情以及正在发生的事情的证据的文件——已经送达了各个政府部门。在它的旅程中，它发生了变化，因为现在它上面几乎是物理地附加着，
paper clipped on the front, in effect, is a demand from the Jewish leadership, you know, headquartered in Jerusalem, Chaim Weizmann, who would go on to be the first president of the state of Israel. Moshe Shertog then would become Israel's second prime minister. They have attached a demand and other Jewish leaders have done the same saying, here's the evidence of what's going on in Auschwitz. Now we call on you to bomb the railway tracks to this killing factory. If this is a factory, then take out the conveyor belt, which is the railway tracks to this killing factory. If this is a factory, then take out the conveyor belt, which is the railway tracks. So now Churchill and Roosevelt are not just discussing, my word, isn't this awful, these terrible things that are going on. There is a
实际上是用回形针夹在最前面的是来自犹太人领导层的要求，你知道的，总部设在耶路撒冷，哈伊姆·韦茨曼，他后来成为以色列国的第一任总统。莫舍·谢托克后来成为以色列的第二任总理。他们附加了一项要求，其他犹太人领导人也做了同样的事情，他们说，这里是奥斯威辛正在发生的事情的证据。现在我们呼吁你们轰炸通往这座杀人工厂的铁路线。如果这是一个工厂，那就摧毁传送带，也就是通往这座杀人工厂的铁路线。如果这是一个工厂，那就摧毁传送带，也就是铁路线。所以现在丘吉尔和罗斯福不仅仅是在讨论，天哪，这太可怕了，这些正在发生的糟糕事情。有一个
tangible proposal. Churchill discusses it with Anthony Eden and gives what Churchill's biographer, Martin Gilbert, says is the most direct instruction he ever gives in the course of the whole of the Second World War, which he says, no need to take this to cabinet. Get anything out of the air ministry you can. Invoke me if necessary. Direct, let's do this, he's effectively saying. Eden goes to Archibald Sinclair, the minister in charge of the Air Force, and says, how about it? Sinclair looks at it and says, hmm, this is an operation that would have to be done by day. We only, we, the RAF, are bomb at night. This is over to the Americans. And Eden, even though he's had that direct instruction from Churchill, basically leaves it at that. He doesn't press Sinclair or say, no, come on, let's think of a way around it. So that's a sort of practical objection.
切实可行的提议。丘吉尔与安东尼·艾登进行了讨论，并给出了丘吉尔的传记作家马丁·吉尔伯特所说他在整个第二次世界大战期间发出的最直接的指示，他说，没必要把这个提交给内阁。从空部（Air Ministry）弄来任何你能弄到的东西。如有必要，搬出我的名义。直接做吧，他实际上是这么说的。艾登找到负责空军的大臣阿奇博尔德·辛克莱，说，你看这怎么样？辛克莱看了一眼，说，嗯，这是一次必须在白天进行的行动。我们，皇家空军，只能在夜间轰炸。这得交由美国人处理。而艾登，尽管得到了丘吉尔的直接指示，基本上也就置之不理了。他没有施压辛克莱，也没有说，不，拜托，让我们想个办法绕过它。所以这是一种现实层面的反对意见。
And it does go over to Washington. And meanwhile, Washington, by the way, has received the report through multiple channels of their own. But it goes through this bureaucratic maze where people say, this seems more your department than mine, we should all get a response. And it's another five days here, seven days there, different departments in Washington. It has to get from the office where it was first picked up in Switzerland over to the United States. Delay, delay, delay. And at this point, the Jews of Hungary, the community that was most in Rudolf Werber's mind, in a way, because he knew they were the
而且它确实转到了华盛顿。与此同时，顺便说一句，华盛顿通过他们自己的多个渠道收到了这份报告。但它陷入了官僚主义的迷宫，人们说，这似乎比我的部门更属于你的部门，我们都应该做出回应。这里又是五天，那里又是七天，华盛顿的不同部门。它必须从最初在瑞士被获取的办公室传送到美国。拖延，拖延，拖延。而此时，匈牙利的犹太人，这个鲁道夫·韦尔巴脑海中最挂念的社群，在某种程度上，因为他知道他们是
last Jews of Europe not yet pulled in to the Nazi inferno, they are being killed at this point at a rate of 12,000 to 15,000 a day. So Churchill has responded with the kind of moral sense of shock and horror that you might expect. But what is going on in the minds of all these bureaucrats and officials and officers that is making them not think, well, we've got to act on this? Well, it's a combination of practical objections like the one Sinclair made about the right time to do the bombing. In Washington, there's this view which comes from the top. It comes from Roosevelt, which is, look, anything which diverts from the war effort, the effort to defeat Hitler is a distraction. We shouldn't do it. And this will take us, of course, as it happens, it would have been three or four kilometer diversion from other industrial targets that the Allies were bombing in Nazi-occupied Poland. So it was barely a diversion. But there's also, there's practical, but there's also prejudice. And there are Whitehall officials who read this report, who say, for example, you know, we should allow for a certain degree of Jewish exaggeration when reading this testimony. Later
欧洲最后一批尚未被拉入纳粹地狱的犹太人，他们此时正以每天 12,000 到 15,000 人的速度被杀害。所以丘吉尔做出了那种你可能会预料到的、带有道德感的震惊和惊恐的回应。但是所有这些官僚、官员和军官的心里到底在想什么，才让他们没有去想“嗯，我们必须对此采取行动”？好吧，这结合了实际的反对意见，比如辛克莱对轰炸的最佳时机所提出的看法。在华盛顿，有一种来自高层的观点。它来自罗斯福，那就是，听着，任何转移战争努力的事情，即击败希特勒的努力，都是一种干扰。我们不应该这样做。这会带走我们——当然，碰巧的是，这本来只需要偏离盟军在纳粹占领的波兰轰炸的其他工业目标三四公里。所以这几乎不算是一种干扰。但其中既有实际因素，也有偏见。白宫办公厅（Whitehall）的官员在阅读这份报告时说，例如，你知道的，我们在阅读这份证词时，应该考虑到一定程度的犹太人夸大。后来
on, there's a foreign office official who says, I think this office, the foreign office, has already used up too much time on these, quote, wailing Jews, unquote. And so those memoranda, I quote from them and cite them in the book. There is an equivalent prejudicial reaction in Washington.-Semitism, you know, where people are shown the report, there's a response from Yank magazine, an American army journal that has actually asked for evidence of Nazi war crimes, because they think it will obviously sort of motivate, gee up the GIs. And they are shown the Werber-Wetzler report in English, and they look at it and they send it back saying, this is too Semitic an account. Might the Office of Information not have one that is rather less Jewish? It gives an account of war crimes that is less Jewish in nature. We want different victims,
一名外交部官员说，我认为这个办公室，即外交部，已经在这些所谓的“哭泣的犹太人”（引述完毕）身上花费了太多时间。因此，我引用了这些备忘录，并在书中提到了它们。华盛顿也存在着同等程度的偏见反应。反犹太主义，你知道的，人们被展示了这份报告，《扬子江》杂志（Yank magazine，注：应为美军《士兵报》）做出了一种回应，这是一份美国陆军杂志，它实际上曾要求提供纳粹战争罪行的证据，因为他们认为这显然会某种程度上激励、振奋美国大兵。他们看到了英文版的韦尔巴-韦茨勒报告，看了一眼后将其退回，说，这份陈述太具有闪米特色彩了。新闻办公室难道不能提供一份不那么犹太色彩的报告吗？它对战争罪行的描述在本质上不那么犹太化。我们需要不同的受害者，
please, because our readers won't warm to the idea of Jewish victims. There is also in both London and Washington the view that it will be bad for if public opinion believes this is somehow a war for the Jews. As you know, the isolationist movement in the United States that fought very hard, it was the biggest anti-war movement in American history, still to this day, by the way, had campaigned for Roosevelt not to join the war. They said this is a Jew war. There was that movement within the America First movement that said somehow, why do we have to go to war to save the Jews? Churchill and Roosevelt are both aware of that and want to essentially downplay the cause of saving Jewish lives.
拜托，因为我们的读者不会对犹太受害者的想法产生共鸣。伦敦和华盛顿也都有一种观点认为，如果公众认为这在某种程度上是一场为了犹太人的战争，那将产生不好的影响。如你所知，美国坚决反对参战的孤立主义运动——这是美国历史上规模最大的反战运动，至今依然如此，顺便说一句——曾竞选要求罗斯福不要参战。他们说这是一场犹太人的战争。美国第一运动内部存在着那种声音，即为什么我们必须参战来拯救犹太人？丘吉尔和罗斯福都意识到这一点，并希望从根本上淡化拯救犹太人生命的事业。
They are uncomfortable with it. They think it will weaken them. Even though this is genocide, I mean, this is literal genocide. Millions of people are dying, and they think that the cause of saving millions of lives would be unpopular with the British and American public? Isn't it also, isn't it, a couple of things. It's partly that it's too Semitic, as Jonathan says, but is it not also that precisely because it is so vast, people struggle to comprehend it? Well, that's the third leg of this stool. And that's really important,
他们对此感到不安。他们认为这会削弱他们。尽管这是灭绝种族，我的意思是，这是字面意义上的种族灭绝。数百万人正在死去，而他们认为拯救数百万生命的事业会不受英国和美国公众的欢迎？难道不是吗，难道不是，有几个原因。部分原因是它太具闪米特色彩了，正如乔纳森所说，但难道不也是因为正因为它如此宏大，人们难以理解它吗？嗯，这是这把椅子的第三条腿。这真的很重要，
is there's prejudice, there's practicalities, but there's also incomprehension or incredulity, rather. And the test case for this, I think is, I mean, there are multiple people have this reaction. There's one story I tell in the book that I think is very powerful. Felix Frankfurt, a Jewish judge on Roosevelt, on the Supreme Court in the Roosevelt era, meets a messenger from the Polish underground, not Jewish actually, who comes to see him, saw Roosevelt too, Saw Anthony Eden. Jan Karski, his name was. And he tells him what's going on in the Nazis' attempt to eliminate the Jewish people,
那就是既有偏见，有现实考量，但也有无法理解，或者更准确地说是难以置信。我认为这个案例是——我的意思是，有很多人都有这种反应。我书里讲过一个我认为非常有力的故事。费利克斯·法兰克福特，罗斯福时期最高法院的一位犹太法官，会见了来自波兰地下组织的一名信使，实际上并非犹太人，他来拜访他，也见过了罗斯福，见过了安东尼·艾登。他的名字叫扬·卡尔斯基（Jan Karski）。他向他讲述了纳粹消灭犹太人民、
eradicate Jews from the face of the earth. And Frankfurter says to Karski, I don't believe you. And the man who has brought Karski immediately leaps to his feet and starts defending Karski's credentials. And Frankfurter raises his hand and starts defending Karski's credentials. And Frankfurt raises his hand and says, I didn't say he wasn't telling the truth. I said, I don't believe him. I can't believe him. It's impossible to believe. And I quote there, the French Jewish intellectual Raymond Aron, who says when it came to the Holocaust, I knew, but I didn't believe. And because I didn't believe, I didn't know. And the hardest case of the lot is in Hungary and the Hungarian Jewish
将犹太人从地球上根除的企图。法兰克福特对卡尔斯基说：“我不相信你。”而带来卡尔斯基的那个人立即跳起来，开始为卡尔斯基的资历辩护。法兰克福特举起手，开始为卡尔斯基的资历辩护。法兰克福特举起手说：“我没说他没说实话。我说的是，我不相信他。我无法相信他。这令人无法相信。”我在此引用法国犹太知识分子雷蒙·阿隆的话，他说，当谈到大屠杀时，“我知道，但我并不相信。正因为我不相信，所以我并不知道。”其中最困难的案例发生在匈牙利和匈牙利的犹太人
leadership, the people who Rudi Werber most wanted to address. Remember, he wanted to warn those Jews not to get on the trains, because if you get on the trains, this is what awaits you. The report reaches the leadership of the Hungarian Jews in the form of Rezu Kastner, de facto leader of Hungary's Jews, and it reaches them much earlier than Roosevelt or Churchill, who are getting this report in June. Kastner gets it more or less with the day the ink is still wet, in late April, and Kastner essentially puts it in a drawer and does not pass it on to the Jews of Hungary. Now, that's a whole other subject of why Kastner did that. I get into it in the book. He's a hugely controversial figure to this day. Some people think he was a hero because
领导层，也就是鲁迪·韦尔巴最想发出警告的人。记住，他想警告那些犹太人不要上火车，因为如果你上了火车，这就是等待你的命运。这份报告以雷兹索·卡斯特纳（匈牙利犹太人的事实上的领袖）的形式送达了匈牙利犹太人的领导层，而且它比罗斯福或丘吉尔收到这份报告的时间要早得多，后者是在 6 月份才收到这份报告的。卡斯特纳几乎在墨迹未干的时候就拿到了它，在 4 月下旬，而卡斯特纳基本上把它塞进抽屉里，没有把它传达给匈牙利的犹太人。现在，关于卡斯特纳为什么这么做，这是另一个完全不同的课题。我在书中对此进行了探讨。直到今天，他依然是一个极具争议的人物。有些人认为他是英雄，因为
he saved some Jews. Other people think his price for saving those tiny number, 1,600 Jews, was essentially to let 400,000 go to their deaths. And people debate this still. But he, Kastner, was surrounded by fellow members of the Hungarian Jewish leadership who looked at it and said, how can we believe this? We cannot comprehend that the most civilized nation in Europe, the people of Goethe and Kant, the Germans, could possibly be doing this. This is unimaginable. How do we know, says one member of the Hungarian Jewish Council, that this isn't the product of the fevered imagination of two rash young men? And there are more examples, too, of people reading the report and just not being able to believe such a thing were possible in their world.
他拯救了一些犹太人。另一些人认为，他拯救那一小部分人——1600 名犹太人——的代价，基本上是让 40,0000 人走向死亡。人们至今仍在争论这一点。但是他，卡斯特纳，被匈牙利犹太人领导层的其他成员所包围，他们看着这份报告说：“我们怎么能相信这个？我们无法理解，欧洲最文明的国家，歌德和康德的人民，德国人，怎么可能会做出这种事？这简直不可想象。”匈牙利犹太人委员会的一名成员说：“我们怎么知道这不是两个鲁莽的年轻人的狂热想象的产物呢？”还有更多的例子，人们阅读了这份报告，却根本无法相信在他们的世界里会有这种事发生。
Jonathan, just one other institution that famously didn't have divisions, but did have a huge role to play in this whole drama, which is the papacy. And the role played by Pius XII, the Pope, throughout the Second World War. I mean, that's incredibly controversial. What light does the history of the Verba report shed on the role played by the Catholic Church and the Pope in particular in the Holocaust? This interests me too, and it does shed some light. For one thing, when that report is making its journey across multiple paths, one of the key paths, two men, resistance men, meet in the National Gallery and smuggle it from one briefcase to another in the National Gallery in Budapest. They then make six copies. Remember, this is before, now, you know, if we want to publish something, we press a button, there are a million copies everywhere. Each copy had to be handmade, somebody sitting at a typewriter or with carbon paper making a copy. They handmade six copies, and they had in mind who would get them, and they decided senior clerics in Hungary needed to read this. And one of them is taken to the cardinal, the cardinal archbishop in Budapest,
乔纳森，还有一个著名的机构，它没有分裂，但在整个戏剧中发挥了巨大的作用，那就是教皇。在第二次世界大战期间，庇护十二世（教皇）所扮演的角色。我的意思是，这极具争议。韦尔巴报告的历史揭示了天主教堂，特别是教皇在大屠杀中所扮演的角色的什么光芒？这也让我很感兴趣，它确实揭示了一些真相。一方面，当那份报告通过多条路径传播时，其中一条关键路径是，两名抵抗运动成员在国家美术馆会面，在布达佩斯的国家美术馆里将它从一个公文包走私到另一个公文包。然后他们制作了六份副本。记住，这是在现在——你知道的，如果我们想发表什么，按一下按钮，到处都是数百万份副本。每份副本都必须是手工制作的，某个人坐在打字机前或用复写纸制作副本。他们手工制作了六份副本，并且心里盘算着谁该得到它们，他们决定匈牙利的高级神职人员需要阅读这篇东西。其中一份被带给卡尔达（Cardinal），布达佩斯的红衣主教大主教，
who is shown the copy and is told what is happening, and is essentially pleaded with to say, you know, say something to your flock that they mustn't collude with the deportation of Jews who are now being sent out of the Hungarian countryside at a rate of 12,000 to 15,000 a day to their deaths. Until this document, they could say, well, we don't know why they're being sent or what fate awaits them. Now they know. And the archbishop sinks to his knees and says, we don't know why they're being sent or what fate awaits them. Now they know. And the archbishop sinks to his knees and says, we should pray, and then says, I can't do anything until the Pope, the Holy Father, has said nothing and done nothing. Until he says something, my hands are tied. I can't possibly go out, you know, alone. And so the Pope, you know, the Vatican threw an envoy who actually
向他展示了副本，并被告知正在发生的事情，基本上是恳求他说，你知道的，向你的信众说点什么，他们绝不能勾结驱逐现在正以每天 12,000 到 15,000 人的速度被送往匈牙利乡村各地走向死亡的犹太人。在这份文件之前，他们可以说，嗯，我们不知道他们为什么被送走，也不知道等待他们的命运是什么。现在他们知道了。大主教双膝跪地，说，我们不知道他们为什么被送走，也不知道等待他们的命运是什么。现在他们知道了。大主教双膝跪地，说，我们应该祈祷，然后说，在教皇、圣父开口之前，我什么也做不了，他什么也没说，什么也没做。在他开口之前，我的双手被绑住了。我不可能独自一人走出去，你知道的。所以教皇，你知道的，梵蒂冈通过了一名特使，他实际上
meets Werber in a cloistered monastery in the Slovak countryside, a secret meeting after Rudi's escape. He's now, by the way, living under false Aryan papers, given a false name. Walter Rosenberg has become Rudolf Werber, a name he will keep with him for the rest of his life. Fred Wetzler has become Josef Lannik. But Werber and a later escapee are taken to meet an envoy of the Pope. And for six hours, this papal envoy, young man, Monsignor Martellotti, grills Werber and his fellow escapee about Auschwitz. And the two escapees worry that their testimony is somehow not really getting through. It doesn't seem to be resonating with this man who's a representative of the Pope. They're telling him about the gas chambers,
在斯洛伐克乡村的一座修道院里会见了韦尔巴，那是鲁迪逃跑后的一次秘密会面。顺便说一句，他现在正使用伪造的雅利安证件生活，使用着假名。沃尔特·罗斯enberg（Walter Rosenberg）变成了鲁道夫·韦尔巴（Rudolf Werber），这个名字他将在余生中一直保留。弗雷德·韦茨勒（Fred Wetzler）变成了约瑟夫·拉尼克（Josef Lannik）。但是韦尔巴和另一位后来的逃亡者被带去会见教皇的一位特使。整整六个小时，这位教皇特使、年轻人马泰洛蒂蒙席（Monsignor Martellotti）盘问了韦尔巴和他的同伴关于奥斯威辛的事情。两位逃亡者担心他们的证词在某种程度上没有真正传达出去。它似乎没有引起这个教皇代表的共鸣。他们告诉他关于毒气室的事，
the column of smoke that comes out of the chimney day and night as Jewish bodies are burnt, children, men, women. It doesn't seem to be landing. And eventually, Werber's fellow escapee says, Catholic priests are being killed there too. And the Monsignor's ears prick up. And now he says, well, you know, tell me more. He said, not the same way. Their bodies arrive. They have already been shot dead, but their bodies are incinerated in Auschwitz. We've seen it, Catholic priests arriving. And in the escapees account, the Monsignor at that point faints on hearing this. And when he comes around, he now says, tell me what I need to do. What should I do? That it's the death of fellow Catholics that finally moves him. He promises
日夜从烟囱里冒出来的浓烟，因为犹太人的尸体被焚烧，儿童、男人、女人。这似乎没有产生效果。最后，韦尔巴的逃亡同伴说：“天主教神父也在那里被杀。”蒙席的耳朵竖起来了。现在他说：“好吧，你知道的，告诉我更多。”他说：“不是用那种方式。他们的尸体抵达。他们已经被枪杀致死，但他们的尸体在奥斯威辛被焚化。我们看到了，天主教神父们到了那里。”根据逃亡者的说法，蒙席听到这里当场晕倒了。当他醒过来时，他现在说：“告诉我我需要做什么。我该怎么做？”正是同为天主教徒的死最终打动了他。他承诺
then to get the report to the Vatican. So it takes a long time. And in terms of actually doing anything, it is only after the telegram that Dominic read out at the start by Walter Garrett, a journalist for the Exchange Telegraph Wire Service, which then is published in the Swiss newspapers and goes around the world. It's in the New York Times a few days later. It's only once the report, which they have already seen, is made public that the Pope and Roosevelt actually both make direct diplomatic intervention, as if they are now worried that their own publics know what they know. The Pope writes to the regent, Miklos Horty, who is ruling Hungary, and says, can't bring himself to use the word Jews, by the way. He says, these unfortunate souls,
随后将报告送到梵蒂冈。所以这花了很长时间。而在真正采取行动方面，只有在多米尼克在开头宣读了那封电报之后——该电报由交换电报社（Exchange Telegraph Wire Service）的记者沃尔特·加勒特发出，随后发表在瑞士报纸上并传遍世界。几天后它登上了《纽约时报》。只有当他们已经看过的报告被公之于众时，教皇和罗斯福才真正做出了直接的外交干预，就好像他们现在担心自己的公众知道了他们所知道的事情。教皇写信给统治匈牙利的摄政米克洛什·霍蒂（Miklos Horty），并说——顺便说一句，他甚至无法勉强自己使用“犹太人”这个词。他说，这些不幸的灵魂，
very telling, these unfortunate souls are being deported, and this distresses the Holy Father, and he pleads with Horty to do something. Even that, actually, I'm not sure. And by the way, the Pope does not make that public. It's still a private communication to Budapest. Roosevelt, through an intermediary, cables Horty and says, and remember, this is after D-Day has happened, right? So the war is, you would think it's almost in its closing chapters, and yet the Holocaust is at its peak at this point. More Jews are being killed now every day than at any other point. He writes to Horty saying, it looks like you're going to be on the losing side of the war, a warning that we will hold accountable anyone who has facilitated this deportation and murder of Jews. And finally,
非常说明问题，这些不幸的灵魂正被驱逐，这让圣父感到痛苦，他恳求霍蒂做点什么。甚至连这个，实际上，我也不确定。顺便说一句，教皇并没有将其公之于众。这仍然是发往布达佩斯的私人信件。罗斯福通过中间人向霍蒂发电报说——记住，这是在 D 日（诺曼底登陆）发生之后，对吧？所以这场战争，你可能会认为它已经接近尾声，然而大屠杀在此时达到了顶峰。现在每天被杀害的犹太人比以往任何时候都要多。他写信给霍蒂说，看起来你将处于战争失败的一方，这是一个警告，我们将追究任何协助驱逐和谋杀犹太人的人的责任。最后，
when he sees that warning, Horthy, clearly fearing a war crimes trial, finally blows the whistle and halts the deportation. And I describe how that's done. There's a power struggle within Hungary's ruling circles. What's fascinating about it is it proves that it's possible, that if these puppet leaders, these vassal states, these occupied nations had acted, they did have the capability to do it. The German Nazis were not on the ground in big enough numbers to do the deportation of Jews unless they had the Hungarian authorities working with them. Horthy says no. And at that point, the deportation halts exactly at the moment when the next group of Jews
当他看到那个警告时，霍蒂显然害怕战争罪审判，终于吹响了哨子并停止了驱逐。我描述了这是如何完成的。匈牙利统治集团内部存在权力斗争。这令人着迷的地方在于，它证明这是可能的，如果这些傀儡领导人、这些附庸国、这些被占领国家采取行动，他们确实有能力做到这一点。德国纳粹在地面上的数量没有多到足以在没有匈牙利当局配合的情况下驱逐犹太人。霍蒂说不。正是在那一刻，驱逐行动戛然而止，恰好是在下一批犹太人
were about to board the train, which is the 200,000 Jews of Budapest. They were next, and they were about to be shoved onto those trains, and Horthy holds it. Is that 200,000? Is that basically the number that gets saved? It is. I qualify it because even though Horthy orders the deportation, and even though literally a train on its way to Auschwitz turns around and comes back, saving the lives of those people, after Horthy is gone and deposed, the Arrow Cross, the fascist militia party that then governs Hungary, engage in murdering Jews themselves. There's a famous episode of drowning Jews in the Danube. And that number, of course, was saved from deportation, but eventually were killed. But at the moment they
即将登上火车的时候，也就是布达佩斯的 20万犹太人。他们是下一批，正要被塞进那些火车里，而霍蒂阻止了。那是 20 万吗？基本上就是获救的人数吗？是的。我对此进行了限定，因为尽管霍蒂下令停止驱逐，并且字面意义上一辆开往奥斯威辛的火车调头开回，挽救了那些人的生命，但在霍蒂离任并被废黜之后，箭头十字党（Arrow Cross，注：匈牙利法西斯政党）——随后统治匈牙利的法西斯民兵党——亲自参与了谋杀犹太人的活动。有一个著名的事件是在多瑙河里淹死犹太人。那个数字，当然，被从驱逐中拯救了出来，但最终还是被杀害了。但在他们
acted, the Werber-Wetzlar report leads to the saving of 200,000 Jewish lives, which is why I argue that Werber, with Wetzler alongside him, deserves to be ranked alongside Oskar Schindler or Anne Frank or Primo Levi as those stories that define our understanding of the Shoah. It is a towering achievement. Verba himself would always focus on the 437,000 Jews who were deported and killed in a space of 56 days, all of which happened after his report. And therefore, as far as he was concerned, all of whom could have been saved. But we should look in the round and count those 200,000 and regard that as one of the great achievements of this period. Just on the 437,000, the 56 days.
采取行动的那一刻，韦尔巴-韦茨勒报告拯救了 20 万犹太人的生命，这就是为什么我认为韦尔巴以及他身边的韦茨勒，理应与奥斯卡·辛德勒、安妮·弗兰克或普里莫·莱维并列，作为定义我们对大屠杀理解的故事。这是一项耸人听闻的成就。韦尔巴本人总是把重点放在在 56 天内被驱逐和杀害的 437,000 名犹太人身上，这一切都发生在他的报告之后。因此，在他看来，这些人本都可以得救。但我们应该全面地看待这个问题，计算这 20 万人，并将其视为这一时期伟大的成就之一。就那 437,000 人、56 天而言。
So is it reasonable to say that had the report been completed, had it made its way to Horthy, let's say, had he immediately acted? I mean, people do act. You talk about vassal states. We did a podcast last year as part of our World Cup marathon about Denmark, about the saving of the Danish Jews. I mean, obviously the numbers are so different,
那么，说如果这份报告已经完成，如果它已经送达霍蒂，比如说，如果他立即采取行动，这合理吗？我的意思是，人们确实采取了行动。你谈到了附庸国。我们去年作为世界杯马拉松的一部分做了一期关于丹麦的播客，关于拯救丹麦犹太人的播客。我的意思是，显然数字非常不同，
and saving them is much less difficult because you can just go over the straits to Sweden, to neutral Sweden, but it can be done. So do you think, I mean, is it legitimate to say, had history worked out slightly differently, had individual people made different choices, almost half a million people would have survived? Yeah, I think Horthy, by what he did in early July 1944, stopping the deportations proves that they could be stopped. And he could have done it earlier. The Nazis had marched in to Hungary in April 1944, become an occupying army, but they used so few people to actually organize the deportations without the collusion of Hungarian authorities on the ground. I don't think it would
拯救他们要容易得多，因为你可以直接穿过海峡到达瑞典，到达中立的瑞典，但这是可以做到的。所以你认为，我的意思是，说如果历史的发展稍微不同，如果个人做出不同的选择，将近五十万人就会幸存下来，这合乎情理吗？是的，我认为霍蒂在 1944 年 7 月初所做的事情，即停止驱逐，证明了它们是可以被阻止的。他本可以更早地做到这一点。纳粹在 1944 年 4 月开进匈牙利，成为一支占领军，但如果没有地面上匈牙利当局的勾结，他们只用了这么少的人来实际组织驱逐，我不认为这会
have been possible. And by the way, just showing the report to Horthy, I don't think would have been enough. He had been shown it. I mean, one of the storylines that I find amazing is that there was a ally for Werber Wetzler inside the royal palace, that his daughter-in-law was a sort of dissenter and a copy had been smuggled to her. And she put that in front of her father-in-law and said, look what is happening to the Jews being deported from our country. Terrible thing, he says. I believe it's true.
是可能的。顺便说一句，仅仅向霍蒂展示这份报告，我认为是不够的。这份报告已经呈给他过。我的意思是，我发现令人惊叹的故事线之一是，在王宫内部有韦尔巴-韦茨勒的盟友，他的儿媳妇是个异见者，一份副本被走私给她。她把那份报告摆在公公面前，说：“看看从我们国家被驱逐的犹太人正在遭受什么。”他说：“太可怕了。我相信这是真的。”
He agrees with her that it's true. He doesn't dispute the, he doesn't have the incredulity problem. He believes it's true and still does nothing. It's only when his own position is threatened by that Roosevelt cable that says war crimes trials are coming, that he act. So I think the capability was there. It proves that there was competence, if you like, that it was within the scope of those authorities if they had wanted to. And of course, this question comes back again to the allied leaders. You know, there is a debate among historians about would bombing the tracks have made a difference?
他同意她的看法，认为这是真的。他没有对……他没有遇到不相信的问题。他相信这是真的，但仍然什么也没做。直到罗斯福发出的那份警告即将进行战争罪审判的电报威胁到他自己的地位时，他才采取行动。所以我认为这种能力是存在的。这证明了确实存在执行能力，如果你愿意这么说的话，如果这些当局愿意的话，这是在他们的职权范围内的。当然，这个问题又回到了盟国领导人身上。你知道的，历史学家之间有一场辩论：轰炸铁路线会有所不同吗？
Wouldn't they have repaired the tracks within a week or so? My response to that is if 15,000 people are being killed every single day, then a week makes a huge difference. That's tens of thousands of people whose children and grandchildren and great-grandchildren would be in our world and never were. So I think there was scope for much more action than ever happened. And the problem, there were many problems, prejudice and practical problems,
他们不是会在一周左右内修复铁路线吗？我的回应是，如果每天有 15,000 人被杀害，那么一周就会产生巨大的差异。那是成千上万人的孩子们、孙子们和曾孙子们本可以来到我们的世界却永远没有来的人。因此，我认为有比实际发生的更多行动的空间。问题在于，有许多问题，偏见和实际问题，
but the one problem that Rudi Verbe himself never really accounted for was the human incapacity to absorb information that is painful, unpalatable, horrific to absorb. And that afflicted, that is not, that's a human thing. There were Jews as well who just could not digest that information. So Jonathan, let's take a break now. And when we come back, perhaps we could look at what the impact of Auschwitz was on Werber himself, who seems to have led a pretty unhappy life. And then just kind of look at the implications of what you're saying there, the impossibility of getting a handle on the scale of the crime that the Holocaust represents. So we'll be back in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
但鲁迪·韦尔巴本人从未真正考虑过的一个问题是，人类吸收痛苦、令人倒胃口、可怕的信息的能力不足。这困扰着——这不是，这是一件人类的事情。也有犹太人根本无法消化这些信息。所以，乔纳森，我们现在休息一下。当我们回来时，也许我们可以看看奥斯威辛对韦尔巴本人产生了什么影响，他似乎过着相当不幸的生活。然后来看看你刚才所说的话的含义，即无法掌握大屠杀所代表的罪行规模的隐含意义。所以我们几分钟后回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的剩余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论的固定去处，
splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The rest is history where we're into the final quarter of this what has admittedly been quite a quite it's quite a bleak story isn't it uh jonathan's no way of of escaping it and it is bleak partly because what really struck me reading your book was that it made me think about
还有少量的八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加成剧集以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的剩余》，我们进入了这一期公认相当沉重、相当令人沮丧的故事的最后四分之一，对吧，乔纳森？没有办法逃避它，它之所以令人沮丧，部分原因在于真正让我阅读你的书时感到震惊的是，它让我思考
the way in which we tell the story of the holoca So if you think of, I mean, the most famous, I guess, the most popularly famous version of the Holocaust is Schindler's List. And Schindler's List ends with this extraordinary moment of catharsis, which everyone will remember. It's incredibly sort of heartrending and tear jerking, where the people, the descendants are kind of queuing up to honour Schindler, I guess. And there's a sort of feeling, you leave the cinema, obviously haunted, and you've seen this incredibly harrowing story, but it has sort of ended on a reassuring note, if you like. Verber's life does not end on that kind of note, really, does it? Because he is haunted by the by it and he's bitter you know there's no moment of salvation and redemption at the end
我们讲述大屠杀故事的方式。所以如果你想想——我的意思是，最著名，我想，最广为人知的大屠杀版本是《辛德勒的名单》。《辛德勒的名单》以一个非凡的宣泄时刻结束，每个人都会记得。它极其感人肺腑、催人泪下，人们、后代们排队向辛德勒致敬，我想。有一种感觉，你离开电影院时，显然心有余悸，你看过这个极其痛苦的故事，但它以一种令人安心的语气结束了，如果你愿意的话。韦尔巴的生活并没有以那种方式结束，对吧？因为他被它所折磨，他很痛苦，你知道，最后没有得到拯救和救赎的时刻，
am i being unfair or is that no i mean you're not and um i wrestle with this a bit because i and others in rudy's life wanted him to have that moment that you're describing at the end of Schindler's List. And I, in the book, sort of try and get that for him. There was an episode which I was so pleased to discover because I wanted this to have happened in his lifetime. And that is that a man called Georg Klein, who had been in Budapest in 1944 at the very same age as Rudy, he was also 19 at that point, had been shown a copy of the report and had acted on it and had chosen to escape rather than get on the trains to what he was being told was a new life in the East. And he made a point 40 years later, after having, by the way, the same experience I had of seeing Rudolf
我是不公平的，还是说——不，我的意思是，你没有。我为此纠结了一会儿，因为我和鲁迪生活中的其他人一样，希望他能有你在《辛德勒的名单》结尾处所描述的那种时刻。我在书里某种程度上试图为他争取到这一点。有一个情节我很高兴能发现，因为我希望这能在他的有生之年发生。那就是一个名叫格奥尔格·克莱因（Georg Klein）的人，1944 年在布达佩斯时与鲁迪同龄，当时他也 19 岁，曾看过那份报告的副本，并据此采取了行动，选择了逃跑，而不是登上那些被告知通往东方新生活的火车。40 年后，他在经历了——顺便说一句，和我一样的经历，即在电影《浩劫》（Shoah）中看到了鲁道夫·
Erbar in the film Shoah, and thinks, hang on, that's the person who must have written that report I saw when I was a teenager. By now, he's living as a very eminent cancer specialist scientist in Sweden. And he crosses all the way over to Vancouver in Canada, on the west coast of Canada, about as far, by the way, as you can get from Auschwitz in Europe, to go and meet the man who he believes saved his life. And he makes this journey and sees Werber and says, it's because of you in this report that I was saved. And I'm so grateful. And not just me, but because of the thing we talked about earlier, the 200,000 in Budapest, you say you did something so extraordinary and so wonderful.
他在电影《浩劫》中看到了埃尔巴，然后心想，等等，那个人肯定写过我十几岁时看过的那份报告。当时，他在瑞典已经是一位非常杰出的癌症专家和科学家。他一路横渡到加拿大温哥华，位于加拿大西海岸，顺便说一句，这几乎是你在欧洲距离奥斯威辛最远的地方，去见那个他认为救了他一命的人。他踏上这段旅程，见到了韦尔伯，并说，正是因为你在这份报告中的内容，我才得以获救。我太感激了。不仅是我，还有我们之前谈到的那件事，布达佩斯的二十万人，你说你做了一件如此非凡、如此美妙的事情。
And that's the note I tried to end the book on, that Gail Klein's children and great-grandchildren are alive, and so are the descendants of those 200,000, more, I write, than even Rudolf Verbe, who was so brilliant at memorizing the detail, more even than he could count. So I want people to take that away. But when Verbe himself heard that, he couldn't hear it. He just focused on the numbers he didn't save. And I've spoken to other people who've worked with or talked to Holocaust rescuers, and apparently this is a very common trait. The Nicholas Wintons of this world, you know, the British man who is credited with saving some 600 lives, all those people involved
这也是我试图为本书画上句号的音符，盖尔·克莱因的孩子和曾孙们都还活着，那二十万人的后代也是如此，甚至更多，我写道，比鲁道夫·韦尔伯还要多，他极其擅长背诵细节，甚至比他所能数出的还要多。所以我希望人们能记住这一点。但当韦尔伯本人听到这话时，他却无法接受。他只关注那些他没有救下的人。我和其他与大屠杀救援人员共事过或交谈过的人聊过，显然这是一个非常普遍的特征。这个世界的尼古拉斯·温顿，你知道的，那个因拯救了大约六百条生命而备受赞誉的英国人，所有那些参与其中的人
in the Kindertransport, what preoccupied them was the ones left behind. That's what they kept thinking about. And Werber couldn't really think of himself as the hero of the 200,000. Rather, he was the one who had not done enough for the 437,000. Now, he didn't channel that all inward and blame himself. Instead, he was full of livid fury at those who had failed to pass on. His warning, top of his list, was the Hungarian Jewish leadership, Rezu Kastner, who he believed, as actually an Israeli court did find, had sold his soul to the devil by working with the Nazis.
在“儿童保育运输”中，让他们魂牵梦绕的是那些被留下的人。那是他们一直思考的事情。韦尔伯无法真正把自己视为那二十万人的英雄。相反，他是那个为那四万三千七百人做得不够的人。现在，他并没有把这一切都转向内心并责怪自己。相反，他对那些未能传递警告的人充满了极度的愤怒。他列出的黑名单之首就是匈牙利犹太人领导层鲁道夫·卡斯特纳，他认为——正如以色列法院确实裁定的那样——卡斯特纳通过与纳粹合作，把灵魂卖给了魔鬼。
Again, highly contested. Others have a different view, but that's, you know, in a way, another story. But Verbe himself was convinced that he, as well as the allies, as well as other leaders in other places, had had the warning that he and Fred had risked everything to bring out and had not done enough with it. And the result was that Verbe himself became a figure that was, in the words of somebody who lived, you know, a fellow Jewish community member in Vancouver said, you know, we couldn't invite Rudy even to Holocaust memorial events in our town,
同样，这极具争议。其他人有不同的看法，但你知道，从某种程度上讲，这是另一个故事。但韦尔伯本人坚信，他以及盟友，还有其他地方的其他领导人，都收到了他和弗雷德冒着一切风险带出来的警告，却没有对它采取足够的行动。其结果是，韦尔伯本人变成了一个这样的人物：用一个在温哥华生活的人的话来说——一个犹太社区的同胞说，你知道的，我们甚至不能邀请鲁迪参加我们镇上的大屠杀纪念活动，
because you did not know that he would not descend into, his words, accusations and rage. There was a symposium in Vancouver every year for high school students about the Holocaust. They had a panel of Holocaust survivors. And Rudolf Werber, the ultimate survivor who had seen everything in Auschwitz, was not invited because he was too angry to be a palatable figure for those high school kids. He wouldn't just say, you know, the evil people in this story is Adolf Hitler and the Nazis and everyone else was good, which is sort of what we want. Instead, he said there was culpability all around. But also, Jonathan, I mean, you call this book The Escape Artist, and there's a sense that even after he's escaped Auschwitz, his life
因为你不知道他会不会陷入——用他的话来说——指责和愤怒之中。温哥华每年都会为高中生举办一次关于大屠杀的研讨会。他们有一个大屠杀幸存者小组。而鲁道夫·韦尔伯，这个看透了奥斯威辛一切的终极幸存者，却没有被邀请，因为他太愤怒了，无法成为那些高中生眼中一个温和讨喜的人物。他不会只是说，你知道，这个故事里的坏人是阿道夫·希特勒和纳粹，其他人都是好人，这有点像我们想要的。相反，他说到处都有罪责。但是，乔纳森，我的意思是，你把这本书命名为《逃脱大师》，有一种感觉，即使在他逃离奥斯威辛之后，他的生活
continues to be a process of flight. So he's in communist Czechoslovakia. He defects from there. He goes to England. He goes to Israel. He goes to Canada. He goes to America. And there seems to be a kind of perpetual restlessness. He separates from his wife.
仍然是一个不断逃亡的过程。所以他在共产主义捷克斯洛伐克。他从那里叛逃。他去了英国。他去了以色列。他去了加拿大。他去了美国。似乎有一种永无止境的动荡。他与妻子分居了。
His elder daughter commits suicide. And it's evident that that shadow is never really escaped. I mean, I guess when you've lived through what he lived, I mean, it's just so unimaginable what the impact of it must have been that it must surely have shadowed him right up to the day of his death. his first wife. I think I mentioned when we spoke last time that I managed to track her down and find her just weeks before her death at age 93. And she told me about the marriage together and how terrible it was. It was so acrimonious, the divorce. The years later, she gave me actually a red suitcase full of his letters. And that was the moment when she passed that to me that I thought, okay, I am somehow meant to write this story. But what came through in those letters was tremendous acrimony and bitterness. But age 93, she was able to say, you know,
他的第一任妻子。我想我上次说话时提到过，设法追踪并找到了她，就在她 93 岁去世前几周。她告诉我他们在一起的婚姻以及它是多么糟糕。离婚是如此的充满怨恨。几年后，她实际上给了我一个装满他信件的红色手提箱。当她把那个交给我时，我想，好吧，我某种程度上注定要写这个故事。但那些信件中透露出的是巨大的怨恨和痛苦。但在 93 岁高龄时，她能够说，你知道，
we were both so damaged. I mean, she was a Holocaust survivor too, in the sense she had been on the run in Slovakia. She'd never been in a camp, but she'd been in hiding. She'd lived on false papers and so on. We were both so damaged. And so no wonder that he was, for her, in her eyes, a terrible husband, an unfaithful husband, and this distrust, this paranoia, which had helped him in Auschwitz because he didn't trust the wrong people, made him impossible to live with, she said. All that said, he did then make a new life in Vancouver.
我们两个都受过太大的伤害。我的意思是，她也是大屠杀幸存者，从某种意义上说，她在斯洛伐克一直在逃亡。她从未进过集中营，但她一直在躲藏。她使用假身份证件生活等等。“我们两个都受得伤太重了。难怪在她的眼中，他是一个糟糕的丈夫，一个不忠的丈夫，这种不信任，这种偏执——这在奥斯威辛救了他，因为他不信任错误的人——让她无法与之共处，”她说。尽管如此，他后来在温哥华开创了新生活。
He married again a second wife who was, and I don't think this is a coincidence, a whole generation younger and from a continent away from the Holocaust. She was an American who, when he met her, was 24 years old, utterly unmarked by the trauma of Europe, as he would have felt it. And he was there on the far west coast of Canada. I think these things are not coincidences. And she described a man who could be playful, who took great pleasure in the very simple things in life that, you know, enjoyed being inside when it was raining, would look outside and say, isn't that wonderful?
他又结了婚，娶了第二任妻子，我不认为这是一个巧合，她比他年轻整整一代，而且来自一个远离大屠杀的大陆。她是一个美国人，当他遇到她时 24 岁，完全没有受到欧洲创伤的印记，就像他所感受到的那样。而他当时在加拿大遥远的西海岸。我认为这些事情绝非巧合。她描述了一个能够嬉戏玩耍的男人，他在生活中非常简单的事情中获得巨大的快乐，你知道，下雨天喜欢呆在室内，会看着外面说：“那不是很棒吗？”
Because this is somebody who had been naked in the frozen waste of my Danek or Auschwitz. He could enjoy practical jokes and he would sort of be quite goofy. And she describes a man who somehow was able to find a new life. He was very committed as a scientist, you know, as a biochemist, teaching at the University of British Columbia. And he would be very insistent, oh, you know, Auschwitz and the Holocaust takes up 1% of my time, no more. Nevertheless, I've gone through the papers, files upon files upon files of material on this subject. He would be testifying at war crimes trials. He testified against a notorious Holocaust denier in Canada. He was on the stand for days. When he was ill, finally with a terminal
因为这是一个曾在马伊达内克（Majdanek）或奥斯威辛的冰冻荒原中赤身裸体的人。他可以享受恶作剧，并且会表现得相当滑稽。她描述了一个不知何故能够找到新生活的男人。他作为一名科学家非常投入，你知道，作为一名生物化学家，在不列颠哥伦比亚大学（University of British Columbia）教书。他会非常坚持地说：“哦，你知道的，奥斯威辛和大屠杀只占我时间的 1%，绝不多。”尽管如此，我还是浏览了关于这个主题的文件、一份又一份的文件、一堆又一堆的资料。他将在战争罪审判中作证。他在加拿大指证了一名臭名昭著的大屠杀否定论者。他在证人席上呆了好几天。当他生病时，最后患上了晚期……
illness, he said to a friend when the illness had got the better of him, the Gestapo have finally caught up with me. When he was living in England, he drove past Battersea power station, saw the chimneys and said, it reminds me of Auschwitz. Of course he couldn't escape it. That shadow was there all the time. I found in his papers a birthday greeting he had sent to his youngest daughter when she turned 44. And he reminded her that 44 was his lucky number. Why? Because his Auschwitz number was 44070. He thought 44 was his lucky number because that was part of the number he'd had in Auschwitz. So this is a complicated man, you know, in every conceivable way, who both found a new life, and yet at every turn,
病情恶化时，他对一位朋友说，盖世太保最终还是追上我了。当他住在英国时，他开车路过巴特西发电厂，看到烟囱便说，这让我想起了奥斯威辛。当然，他是无法逃避这一切的。那种阴影一直挥之不去。我在他的文件中发现了一封生日贺信，那是他写给小女儿的，当时她44岁。他提醒女儿，44是他的幸运数字。为什么？因为他在奥斯威辛的编号是44070。他认为44是他的幸运数字，因为那是他在奥斯威辛编号的一部分。所以这是一个复杂的人，你知道，在任何可以想象的方面，他既找到了新生活，但在每一个转折点，
Auschwitz was the event which had shaped him. And of course, how could it be any other way? This is a massive question, Jonathan, but do you think part of the reason that he's not so well known is that we expect Holocaust survivors to be martyrs only, to be kind of saintly? And he was too spiky. He's too difficult. He doesn't fit in. We have now, I mean, we can get into this issue of where the Holocaust stands in that kind of moral consciousness as this kind of almost sacred transcendent moment. But he doesn't fit that, does he? view that we are very unfair in what we demand of Holocaust survivors, but I would also say it goes wider of survivors of great traumatic events, that we do endow them with a kind of saintliness, and we want them, therefore, to dispense a kind of consoling, healing wisdom to us,
奥斯威辛是塑造他一生的事件。当然，怎么可能不是呢？这是一个巨大的问题，乔纳森，但你认为他不那么广为人知的另一个原因，是不是因为我们期望犹太人大屠杀的幸存者只能是烈士，只能像圣人一样？而他太特立独行了。他太难对付了。他格格不入。我们现在——我的意思是，我们可以探讨大屠杀在道德意识中处于什么位置，作为一个几乎神圣的、超越的时刻。但他不符合这一点，对吧？对于我们对大屠杀幸存者提出的要求，我们的看法非常不公平，但我也要说，这种现象不仅限于大屠杀，对于经历过巨大创伤事件的幸存者也是如此，我们赋予了他们一种圣洁感，因此我们希望他们能向我们散发一种安慰、治愈的智慧，
as if their touch will somehow sanctify us. And, you know, there's very, very few Holocaust survivors left now. The numbers are very dwindling. But when you hear them interviewed on the radio, the interviewer adopts a tone of voice they also have with kind of Dalai Lama or something, you know, this sort of hushed reverence. And they want an uplifting experience.
仿佛他们的抚摸能以某种方式净化我们。而且，你知道，现在幸存下来的大屠杀幸存者已经非常非常少了。人数正在急剧减少。但当你听到他们在电台上接受采访时，采访者采用了一种对待达赖喇嘛或类似人物时才有的语调，你知道的，那种压低声音的敬畏。他们想要一种精神振奋的体验。
And I think this is such an unfair demand to make. And Rudy was so aware of it. I found in his papers a letter he wrote to a BBC producer. The BBC producer had invited him to come on a TV documentary. And Rudy says, I must warn you, I am not the cliched Holocaust survivor. I won't be that person for you. I'm going to be spiky and awkward and difficult. And the main way I'm going to be difficult is I'm going to tell you that there is guilt to go around here. And everyone you think is the heroes of this story, and that might be Jewish leaders, but it might be Roosevelt, it might be Churchill. Well, it's not always as simple as that. You know, he was keen and he was very tailored, by the way, I should say this to his audience. When he was in Germany, he absolutely pointed the finger at Germany and Nazis and Hitler and was very clear on it.
我认为这是一个非常不公平的要求。鲁迪对此非常清楚。我在他的文件中发现了他写给BBC制片人的一封信。BBC制片人邀请他参加一个电视纪录片。鲁迪说，我必须警告你，我不是那种老套的大屠杀幸存者。我不会为你扮演那种角色。我会表现得尖锐、尴尬和难以相处。而我最难以相处的地方在于，我要告诉你，这里每个人都有罪。你认为这个故事中的英雄——可能犹太领袖是，但也可能是罗斯福、丘吉尔。嗯，事情并没有那么简单。你知道，顺便说一句，我很想对他的听众说，他很敏锐，而且很有针对性。当他在德国时，他明确地把矛头指向德国、纳粹和希特勒，态度非常明确。
But if he was talking to Americans or Brits, he would mention the failures in London and Washington and so on. He was difficult. And I think that's why he wasn't famous. He didn't get the invitation even in Vancouver. But that's also why he was not invited to all the big conferences and elevated into that stature. I think it's really telling that the really very best, in my view, chroniclers of the Holocaust sought him out. They understood how important he was. Claude Lansman puts him as a key witness in the film Shoah. Martin Gilbert spoke to him
但如果他跟美国人或英国人交谈，他就会提到伦敦和华盛顿等地的失职。他很难对付。我想这就是他为什么不出名的原因。他甚至在温哥华都没有收到邀请。但这也是他没有被邀请参加所有大型会议并被推崇到那种地位的原因。我觉得非常能说明问题的是，在我看来，那些真正最优秀的大屠杀记录者都曾找过他。他们明白他有多重要。克劳德·兰斯曼将他视为电影《浩劫》中的关键见证人。马丁·吉尔伯特经常与他交谈，
often for his book, Auschwitz and the Allies, and other books. The top two or three people got it, but I think other people thought, difficult character, let's steer clear. But Jonathan, to go back to Auschwitz, you have this terrifying description of what the inhabitants of Auschwitz looked like and how, and to Walter, to Rudy, they don't seem human. The living dead, walking skeletons with bowed heads and sunken hollow eyes, non-men whose muscle and flesh had wasted away, who were expiring in plain sight, the breath of life leaving them slowly but inexorably. And I think that is how, perhaps in the imagination, that is how we think of the people who die in Auschwitz,
为了他的书《奥斯威辛与盟军》以及其他书籍。前两三个人看出来了，但我认为其他人会想，这是一个难搞的角色，我们还是离远点吧。但是，乔纳森，回到奥斯威辛，你对奥斯威辛居民的长相有着可怕的描述，以及——对沃尔特和鲁迪来说，他们看起来并不像人。行尸走肉，低着头、眼眶深陷的骷髅，那些肌肉和血肉已经消瘦殆尽、非人的生灵，他们在光天化日之下消逝，生命的气息缓缓但不可阻挡地从他们身上离去。我想，也许在想象中，这就是我们认为死在奥斯威辛的人的方式，
is as people in a sense who are already dead, who have already passed into a dimension of shadow. It's because Rudy is such a distinct individual. He's so alive. He's not a ghoul. He's not a thing of shadow. He is a living, breathing person. But that, it seems to me, is why your book, I am sure, you say that you want him to rank alongside Anne Frank and Primo Levi, but I'm sure your book will rank alongside Anne Frank's diary and Primo Levi's book as a record of what it was like to be human amid all that suffering, of what it's like to be a living individual amid the six million. Because that is the problem, isn't it? With making sense of the Holocaust, of fathoming the Holocaust, of presenting the Holocaust as a field of study, is how do you
把他们看作某种意义上已经死去的人，已经进入阴影维度的人。正因为鲁迪是一个如此鲜明的个体。他是如此充满生机。他不是一个食尸鬼。他不是阴影中的事物。他是一个活生生、有呼吸的人。但在我看来，这就是为什么你的书——我确信，你说你希望他能与安妮·弗兰克和普里莫·莱维并列——我确信你的书将与安妮·弗兰克的日记和普里莫·莱维的书并列，成为在所有苦难中保持人性是什么感觉的记录，成为在六百万人中作为一个活生生的个体的记录。因为这就是问题所在，不是吗？要理解大屠杀，要探究大屠杀，要将大屠杀作为一门研究领域呈现出来，问题就在于，你如何
extract individuals from the totality of those millions? I mean, even doing this, Tom, you know, when Jonathan says 15,000 a day, 20,000 a day, you have to do a bit of work. You have to translate it into something concrete. And that's quite difficult to do. And I agree with you. I think, I mean, well, are you conscious of this, Jonathan? Do you think we dehumanize the Holocaust almost by turning it into numbers rather than
从数百万人的整体中提取出个体？我的意思是，汤姆，即使在做这件事时，你知道的，当乔纳森说一天一万五千人、一天两万人时，你必须做一些工作。你必须把它转化为具体的东西。这其实很难做到。我同意你的看法。我的意思是，乔纳森，你意识到这一点吗？你认为我们通过把大屠杀变成数字，而不是
countless individuals? But there's no, I mean, that's what's amazing about this book is that by and large, we don't, you know, you go to Auschwitz, you die. That's what it's for. So we don't have records of what it's like, but this gets you as close as it's probably possible to get to the lived experience of all those horrors. Well well you do me in this book great honor by what you've just said there tom i'm honored by what you said there the idea that it might rank alongside those stories uh that that is huge to me and so i'm absorbing that i think the idea of an individual and hearing of a life was very important to me if I was ever going to go anywhere near this subject,
无数的个体，从而在某种程度上将它非人性化了吗？但没有——我的意思是，这本书的神奇之处就在于，大体上我们没有这样做，你知道，你去了奥斯威辛，你就会死。这就是它的目的。所以我们没有关于那是怎样一种体验的记录，但这让你尽可能接近所有这些恐怖的亲身经历。好吧，汤姆，你刚才所说的话对这本书给予了极大的荣誉，我为你所说的话感到荣幸，那种认为它可能与那些故事并列的想法——这对我有重大意义，所以我正在吸收这种想法。我认为，拥有一个个体的概念并听取一个生命的故事，对我来说非常重要，如果我打算涉足这个主题的话，
because it's almost the only way you can make it, not just a statistic. I think the idea that Auschwitz, even when it's known, and we all see those polls where it shows that people don't know what it was, et cetera, and that it's passing into not just history, but perhaps ignorance. For the people who do know of it, you know, they know six million died. There was gas chambers. That's it. That's sort of it. What people know, they imagine, yeah, maybe you got off a train, you were gassed.
因为这几乎是让你不把它仅仅变成一个统计数字的唯一方法。我认为，奥斯威辛的概念，即使在为人所知时——我们都看到过那些民意调查，显示人们不知道它是什么，等等，它不仅正在成为历史，也许还在走向无知。对于那些确实了解它的人来说，你知道的，他们知道六万人死了。有毒气室。仅此而已。这就是全部。人们所知道的、想象的是，是的，也许你下了火车，就被毒死了。
That's what people know. And actually, the idea that this was a, one holocaust survivor auschwitz survivor described as a metropolis of death it was a place with a society with a black economy with a hierarchy with competing factions with politics in a way i mean that restores something of the reality of it and therefore the humanity of the people who went through it. And, you know, I have been very heartened by people who've said to me, look, I really thought I was quite knowledgeable about this. But now that I've read this, I realized what I didn't know and how much there is to know. I think there's, you know, it is about somehow restoring the dignity to these people who went through this. You know, it is about somehow restoring the dignity to these people who went through this.
这就是人们所知道的。事实上，认为这是一个——正如一位奥斯威辛大屠杀幸存者所描述的“死亡大都市”，它是一个拥有社会、黑色经济、等级制度、相互竞争的派系以及政治的地方，从某种程度上说，这恢复了它的一部分现实，从而也恢复了经历过这一切的人的人性。而且，你知道，那些对我说“看，我真的觉得自己对此相当了解，但读了这些之后，我才意识到我所不知道的有多少，还有那么多东西需要了解”的人，让我备受鼓舞。我认为，你知道的，这在某种程度上是关于恢复这些经历过这一切的人的尊严。你知道，这在某种程度上是关于恢复这些经历过这一切的人的尊严。
You know, even that small fleeting story that you referred to in our earlier conversation, Dominic, about the Czech mother who said, you know, she got off the train. She tells the SS man this, you know, it can't be true, can it, that we're all going to be killed. Just by telling her story, you know, for a moment, she's somebody who died, her children would never, never had any life at all. For a moment, there's a humanity that is restored to that person, not much, because we don't know her name or anything else. So that's the great challenge with this and with atrocities in other periods and other times is that they how do we rescue them from oblivion and the oblivion that comes when they are just a number and he is one person but through him i think we somehow can get a bit more of a grip on the whole thing and in a strange way that's what he always wanted us to do. I mean, that's what's so strange to me about
你知道，甚至你在我们先前的对话中提到的那个转瞬即逝的小故事，多米尼克，关于那个捷克母亲的故事，她说，你知道的，她下了火车。她对党卫军军人说，你知道的，这不可能是真的吧，我们不可能都要被杀掉。仅仅是通过讲述她的故事，你知道的，在某一刻，她成了一个死者，而她的孩子本绝不会有任何生活。在某一刻，人性回到了那个人身上，虽然不多，因为我们不知道她的名字或其他任何信息。所以，这就是这项工作以及其他时期和时代暴行的巨大挑战，即我们如何把他们从遗忘中拯救出来，拯救他们免于沦为仅仅是一个数字的遗忘。而他是一个人，但通过他，我认为我们不知何故能更好地掌控整件事情，而奇怪的是，这正是他一直希望我们去做的。我的意思是，这对我来说最奇怪的地方在于
him is that his whole life, and even after his death, he's still testifying and warning us of what happened in Auschwitz. I mean, what he did as a 17, 18, 19-year-old is carrying on 80 years later. Thank you, Jonathan. So your book, The Escape Artist, can't recommend it highly enough. Thank you all very much for listening. Thank you, Jonathan, for coming on. And we'll be back soon. I hope there's something perhaps
他的一生，甚至在他死后，他仍在作证，并警告我们奥斯威辛发生了什么。我的意思是，他在17、18、19岁时所做的事，在80年后仍在延续。谢谢你，乔纳森。所以你的书《逃生艺术家》，我强烈推荐。非常感谢大家的收听。谢谢乔纳森的光临。我们很快就会回来。我希望会有一些可能
slightly less overpowering and overwhelming. Thanks very much for listening. Bye-bye. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
不那么压抑和势不可挡的内容。非常感谢收听。再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝娱乐圈八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家节目和提前获得现场门票，本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。